to india now where there has been a rise
in the number of attacks on churches and
christian gatherings they are being
carried out by right-wing hindu groups
emboldened by new laws that crack down
on religious conversion critics say
these groups are abusing the laws to
push their own agenda often facing no
consequences themselves
dw delhi correspondent nimisha jasmal
traveled to the town of fubali in the
the southern state of karnataka to meet
a pastor who has shut down his church
in the face of continued abuse
the highlight of pastor somo avradi's
week has always been the sunday service
but now he's praying alone at his church
in hubli
it is the first time he has been back in
more than three months
last october
as the pastor was on his way to the
church
he received urgent phone calls warning
him that volunteers linked with hindu
right-wing groups were disrupting the
sunday prayer gathering there
they had barged in
and started loudly chanting hindu hymns
when the pastor arrived to question them
they claimed that they had proof he had
tried to forcefully convert a hindu man
in their midst
the pastor said he'd never met the
alleged victim before
yet he was still taken to the police
station on charges of verbally abusing a
man from a protected caste
i was the one who called the police
i was going to file a case against them
but they pushed me aside and started
beating me they beat seven members of my
church
they entered the police station and
abused and threatened
no action has been taken against the
hindu group
it was the pastor who spent 11 days in
jail
and he continues to face charges
it didn't end there
the pastor's family was terrorized in
their neighborhood
their landlord threatened with harm if
he didn't evict them
they were forced to move
they also had to pull their daughter out
of school
because she was being bullied
my children's classmates were harassing
them taunting them that their father had
been sent to prison
my children were embarrassed i had to
pull them out of school they haven't
been able to return
over the last year
christian groups have reported a spike
in similar attacks in harassment in
karnataka especially after plans for a
new law were announced
the state of karnataka is in the process
of passing an anti-conversion law which
targets conversions considered
fraudulent or forced but the definition
of what is illegal is very broad and the
punishments very strict right-wing hindu
groups here strongly support the law
manjunad hibser was amongst the men who
stormed pastor avaradis church
he alleges that christian congregations
like avaradis brainwash hindus into
rejecting their religion
or offer financial incentives to convert
the law he says will give them strong
grounds to put an end to this
once the law comes we can demolish these
churches we are already prepared to
demolish them but we are waiting for the
lord
once it is passed our hands are no
longer tied we are free to take action
we can catch them and report them to the
police
for now pastor abrahadi visits church
members at home and only in areas
considered safe
this man and his family were also forced
out of their village after the attack on
the church
but they say they find comfort in prayer
all they want is the freedom to do so in
peace
well the w's daily correspondent nimisha
jaswal filed this report and she joins
us now from daily uh namisha these
attacks have been going on for some time
why is the government not doing more to
protect these christian communities
the simple reason is that the government
is often one of those making these
allegations in the case that we just
watched the bjp's elected representative
was actually one of the people who led
the protests following the pastor's
arrest and actually called for action
against him now of course it's important
to note here that the in that india's
christian community is one of the oldest
in asia and dates back centuries yet the
target of these groups as well as bjp
legislators is those who were born hindu
and have either officially converted or
are covertly believing in christianity
but of course bjp legislators themselves
have actually been present or have made
speeches that directly call for action
and sometimes even violence against
these communities and they are of course
also pushing anti-conversion laws across
the country
well tell us more about this this
anti-conversion bill what's its purpose
well to look at the one in karnataka
gerhard interestingly it's called the
freedom of religion bill and if you look
at it simply it actually just prescribes
ways to convert for example it says that
you should let authorities know a month
before converting and also report your
conversion a month after it however all
these reports actually allow for time of
for time for chris for hindu right-wing
groups to attack or abuse these people
so this is generally avoided in addition
many kinds of conversions are considered
fraudulent or forced and can be charged
the word allurement for example is used
for what is considered illegal and that
has such a broad definition that pretty
much anyone can be charged with forcing
conversions and anyone can report these
conversions as well not just family but
neighbors and bystanders too and strict
action is taken against these people
india has also been recording a rise in
attacks on minorities for quite some
time is this impacting the modi
government's popularity there
well while international condemnation
and attention has been brought to the
fact that attacks on minorities are
rising in india domestically political
analysts believe that this could
actually be adding to the modi
government's popularity because of this
government's agenda of a hindu rashtra
or a hindu nation which is being
promoted not only through policies like
these but also laws and as well as
silence on attacks on minorities now
this for example can can include saying
that christians are forcing conversions
or saying that muslims are marrying
hindu girls and practicing love jihad
all of these allegations demonizing
minorities and saying that hindus are
under threat and that hindus should take
over power and should be the should be
the religion that drives the nation this
of course plays well amongst the voters
for prime minister narendra modi's
government as well
the dws animation jazz while they are
reporting thank you very much nimisha